we sin reading but we also sin not
reading my newest thriller novel when
the corn is waste hot now you may be
wondering what the [ __ ] this book is
about and why you want it in your life
so i'm teaming up with amazing people to
talk about it like these guys
so here's your don't take my word for it
take their word for cliche and seriously
thanks for all your support and for
claiming your copy of my book today
so
one minute and 40 seconds of being
treated like drew barrymore in 50 first
dates
wasn't this club filled with people
either that bomb was very efficient or
the rubble to corpse ratio seems a
little off here it was
inevitable it wasn't inevitable was it
you could have left dooney world at any
point but you seem pretty set on playing
boba father and that directly led to
these lovely people being vaporized also
who's this guy again he's been holding
off the spice trade single-handedly i
told him we could shut it down
that's not free finnick might be wasted
in this show but she would be excellent
at tv since marcespa can become a
prosperous city under our protection are
we counting garcia's business no putting
that behind us then our track record's
pristine let marshall vancouver the
people of moss belgium freetown is its
name now did mando mommy not teach you
good manners let your elder talk
if you want to abandon moss espan hide
in your fortress go ahead
we're staying
the people who live here need our
protection which is screenwriter code
for jabba's palace is a bit too op and
we need the audience to think bob
domanda fed are actually at risk was
your venture successful
you won't have to worry about free town
nice work mr bane i mean that response
was vaguer than i'd hoped but i'm gonna
trust you dealt with the whole of
freetown and not just their sheriff you
know so there's no chance they ex
machina this [ __ ] at the last second i
didn't realize the pike syndicate was so
ruthless
pragmatic
they were charging us protection
justifying tribal displacement what's an
x-wing doing here van service would be
my first guess closely followed by they
couldn't afford to cgi a star destroyer
and luke skywalker
choosing man daddy over luke and yoda's
freaking lightsaber is sin
[Music]
i know an astromech blew the ship good
as long as you know that and we know
that we can all go on happily knowing
that we know all the things that need to
be known to enjoy grogu's convenient
arrival in the finale the mandalorian
roll commercials
i said what i said bring him some dumb
worms i know grogu has eaten many
questionable things but pooh parasites
is where i drama
line
[Music]
oh keep your dome on considering how
powerless r2 is to prevent peli from
taking grogu here i have to wonder why
luke thought it was a good idea what if
this had been literally anyone else on
tatooine synchronized captain morganing
chrysanton is in trandocion territory i
think finnick needs to brush up on her
wikipedia knowledge this is an absolute
liability but i guess one-armed
transitions are about to become all the
rage
all our flanks are covered nobody is
sneaking up on us finnick is basing this
on having two pig people at the starport
a few teen terminators wandering the
streets and ted patrolling town hall
covered this isn't even a light dusting
gamora and nipples have better coverage
than this when the people of freetown
arrive we will have the forces required
to pivot our strength to whatever region
the pikes choose to attack from another
bold claim considering you don't
actually know that the freetonians are
coming or if they do how many they'll
actually number what if it's only oh i
don't know 10 people and a hovercraft
slow cowboy eye contact reveal cliche i
thought i smelled something can you
smell while wearing that helmet either
cadbane smells a fresh bantha fodder and
gym socks or bobas trying to diminish
his morale regardless both of these
things smell of bad etiquette if that's
not the quack to call in the stiffling
slimy yeah well i'm rubber and you're
forgetting that i don't have the
necessary context to understand the damn
thing you just said before you get any
ideas
i've got back shooters too indeed he
does but what he doesn't have is a
helmet so i don't know why fennec and
mano don't blast demon cowboy crazy frog
while they still have a chance sure
their armor can take a few hits in the
meantime you mean the one that massacred
your tuscan family and blamed it on a
speedlike gang which means that boba
murdered the gang for a crime they
didn't commit yes they were by no means
good guys but maybe you should gather a
bit more information than a suspiciously
obvious gang tag before dispensing your
pew pews of justice why aren't the mods
shooting first you have time to make
comps to your allies but have no time to
shoot them based on your observation the
mods watching all these aliens take
their time fumbling with weapons they
barely know how to use tells me the
judgment is not the mod strong suit i
thought we had a treaty
so did i a treaty you barely had a
gentleman's agreement did boba seriously
not think this betrayal was likely or
even possible i once trusted my dad when
he said he would trade me boardwalk but
i still came prepared to flip that
monopoly board the second he betrayed me
admiral ackbar did it better homeless
panic and worry from the civilians
except for this lady who is all for this
chaos i'm still stunned that any amount
of responsibility was entrusted with the
two individuals who have just allowed
themselves to be herded off a cliff edge
anything even running straight at their
enemies would have been better than
relying on a sudden resistance to
gravity i hope she gets there in 40
minutes to end this war would be
terrible if she got caught in traffic or
god forbid a one-sided gun fight
hold up nobody heard the speeder's
approach it was right next to the mods
an aqualish gun fight finnick pulled up
dismounted climbed the building and made
herself comfortable to shoot the enemy
all without being seen or heard i get
that she's a master assassin but the
people of tatooine are oblivious to a
fault manners
i like it unless she's vocalizing
through her nostrils this minimal mask
lowering was pretty pointless
they're here
it was just a matter of time indeed it
was so why are you still here the idea
was to protect the people of mos espa
but since your plan has gone out of the
airlock aren't they better served by
drawing the pikes back to the more
defensible palace and away from all the
civilian homes also i'm no bounty hunter
but you already had one visitor don't
you think it might be better to move
around a little so you're not in an
already known place maybe a flanking
position or up high on the rooftops feel
like this is bounty hunting 101
all three gotchas of my sister turned on
us putting trust into crime lords yeah
they got your good
[Laughter]
i have no compunction whatsoever
genuflecting or even groveling if needs
be what about any veneration of sequence
or general sycophancy that might be
needed say i have a thesaurus too and it
doesn't make me any less annoying either
read it to me tailhead and it's racist
visual definition of getting kneecapped
also why does boba's built-in arsenal
only function along the y-axis the
badasses with jet packs choose this
position instead of any of the widely
available high ground you don't have to
like episode 3 to acknowledge the
lessons it teaches why are 12 people
hiding behind this one tank there's more
coverage to your left and right i do
believe you can die with honor if it's
not done with stupidity
18 people hiding behind the tank
probably won't be shot today why did
they wait till after they turned the
corner to turn their shields on doesn't
appear to affect their maneuverability
so why risk deploying them at the last
possible second it's almost as if they
knew the baubalorian crew had no
intention of firing at them yet also why
weren't the baublorian crew firing at
them yet they think there was a chance
this wasn't going to end in a fire fight
did they think they were on the same
team
honestly i wonder why disney didn't save
us all some time and just titled the
whole damn show everything wrong with
boba fett i'm really not needed here ted
faking your previous injuries is no way
to go about war also i'm not sure why
anybody is bothering to run away as
deadly as these things look they
apparently can't aim lower than a
two-story house the darksaber the most
badass weapon in the galaxy right up
until the plot deems it to be too
powerful and renders it useless we'll
just store that away with the infinity
stones mjolnir in the incredible hulk
anyone else seeing a pattern here a 360
no scope
i feel like she's every npc i've ever
come across in a video game who still
has their shop open and great crisis i
know hell incarnates outside but i'm
gonna still smile through it all because
ignorance is bliss and i have something
i want to give to you turn around i
can't hear you i understand her not
being able to hear mando over the sound
of all the laser fire and stomping
scorpio bots but shouldn't the laser
fire and stomping scorpio bots been clue
enough that this is not a safe place for
her and grosgu also what the [ __ ] is r2
doing right now
oh
okay little guy
i'm happy to see you too oh
two sins all for the most adorable force
hug in the galaxy the spindle board
decides to stop attacking just long
enough for the rancor and fed to have
their dramatic entrance what a
thoughtful piece of programming
okay i officially have no forcing clue
how this shield works i assumed it was
just projected outward from the droid
but the rancor pummeling actually knocks
it over which means the shield is
somehow physically connected to the
equilibrium of the droid itself why why
would you design a shield to be so
specifically weak against a kinetic
attack
[Music]
why does mando wait until after the
rancor has been shot again to darksaber
some sh when you get the chance to
darksaber you darksaber dude huh well
now that i've seen the darksaber slice
through one piece of the droid like a
hot knife through butter but struggle to
penetrate with a stab to the brain
perhaps mando was right to avoid using
this confusing weapon at all why is
mando's jetpack always set to make me
look like a badass instead of zoom me
out of danger when i really need it i'll
distract the droid wouldn't distracting
the droid work better if you were more
than two feet away from the person
you're distracting it from
so earlier on when boba said these two
will destroy the whole city he was just
mad that he wasn't getting in on the
destruction fun too
jet
pack
but i have armor
let's find out can
he not see
the armor
consider this my final lesson look out
for yourself
anything else
is weakness giving life advice to
someone you're about to murder boba
assumes this single stab to the chest
has killed cat bane this is especially
complacent considering how much insanely
unsurvivable [ __ ] we know that boba has
survived will anybody ever go for the
head why does it seem to be baked into
every mega monster's jeans to climb the
tallest tower and be as cinematic as
possible waiting 50 minutes for
something that takes all of one minute
to do i'm really trying to think of a
single situation where a bipedal droid
makes sense on a desert planet is it
just to give people something to laugh
at why does it have to be the right arm
well because if it was a left arm it
feels like a stranger was doing it i
prefer for these things to feel personal
we are not suited for this then what the
[ __ ] have the last seven episodes been
about
no
kids i have to hope at least one person
on the boat team was like hey isn't it a
bit shitty the fans of the mandalorian
are going to be confused as the start of
season three do we really have to force
them to watch every second of content in
order to keep up of course any further
protest would have been met with a swift
force choke by a hooded figure with
dimly lit mouse-like features as it
rasps in disgust this is the way
when is a gift not a gift
back in the pile back in the pile
everyone we're going back to the pipes
now we're going back to the park
[Music]
one two three strikes you're out
one two three strikes you're up one two
three strikes
it's up in the pocket he'll fire to the
right side called by diggs staying low
okay
[Music]
what's your angle my god how can you be
so obtuse what did you call me
i've never seen anything like this
before
seeing cora how impressive was that
it's a fighting pose you're a total
poser